sur les bords de la rivière rouge à
calcutta en français planche de surf sur
l'épaule
anthony colas 46 ans s'en va chevaucher
une vague et les indiens n'en reviennent
toujours pas
or garde ouais t'as vu ça il veut monter
sur un truc ça ressemble un nouveau toit
la vague qu'anthony est venu chercher
jusque on n'est pas une inconnue
c'est un masque à une vague née de la
rencontre de la marée montante et du
courant des clubs décembre
anthony connaît bien le phénomène
cela fait 15 ans qu'ils le trac là où il
se cache en malaisie il a dompté le
bénac le mascaret de la jungle puissant
et destructeur en chine il a surfé le
dragon d'argent au brésil pour aucun
sa quête l'a érigée en véritable
spécialiste mondial du phénomène
anglet dans son bureau du pays basque
anthony étudie répertorier des bus que
les masses car et c'est sa passion c'est
son métier
dans tous ses tiroirs il ya des infos
que je classe que j'arrive sur chaque
filière chaque baie chaque zone
géographique
des photos des textes anciens des cartes
anthony compile tout ce qui a trait au
phénomène pour écrire ensuite des
articles des livres et organiser des
expéditions au tour du monde cette fois
en inde il embarque dans l' aventure des
surfeurs brésiliens
[Musique]
nous
donc on sera deux fois tout s'est très
bien
pour pays basque un nouveau grand voyage
se prépare il aura pour décor calcutta
[Musique]
et vieux taxis des ponts d'un autre âge
calcutta 20 millions d'habitants et au
milieu un surfeur qui cherchent une
bague
[Musique]
pour slalomer entre les singes
les poumons et le linge qui sèche à
calcutta circuler c'est déjà toute une
aventure
je tombé sur un taxi complément est
compétent pour la galère ça avance par
être appliquée dans l'auditoire mais
si on parle en tant l'avancé là il
commence à renégocier trio rock ainsi
qu'à monsieur à calcutta c'est un voyage
dans le temps un voyage dans une ville
bouillonnante surpeuplées et tout
formant une ville prisonnière du passé
[Musique]
la rivière ou but est au coeur de la
cité comme une artère vitale c'est là en
plein centre ville au milieu des ponts
des temples et des bateaux que le
mascaret va débuter
sur la route anthony a rejoint les
autres membres de l'expédition
il y a les brésiliens
un australien et des championnats tous
sont au rendez vous de la grande marée
et du mas cas
on va vers là où la vague sera la plus
forte toute l'énergie se compressent
quand le courant arrive dans le virage
et c'est probablement là prendra le plus
de puissance
peut-être remettre peut-être plus
une vague en plein centre ville les
indiens en ont l'habitude mais des
surfeurs en maillot de bain au milieu de
la circulation et des gourous indiens ça
sert c'est une première
et le choc de cultures se poursuit
jusqu'au bord de la rivière
pendant que les uns vont affronter une
vague les autres baignent les morts
avant de jeter leurs centres dans la
oublient
[Musique]
qu'on est dans un lieu très spécial tant
par sa culture que par sa spiritualité
on a beaucoup à apprendre de cet endroit
nous sommes prêts nous avons déjà des
connaissances des expériences sur
l'autre mascaret et ils le font ça n'a
rien d'une plaisanterie c'est une vague
dangereuse
en période de grandes marées
le phénomène n'apparaît qu'une seule
fois par jour pendant une semaine
il ne faut pas le rater d'autant qu'en
ce moment la lune n'a jamais été aussi
proche de la terre ça arrive tous les
dix-huit ans et ça promet un mascaret
exceptionnel
bakary ben
oui dans ce milieu mais quelle taille
elle va faire aujourd'hui comme ça
assez gros les pêcheurs ont senti
l'arrivée de la vague il faut lever
l'ancré pour se mettre à l'abri
les vaches sacrées fut comme elles le
peuvent tant qu'il est encore temps ok
vous voyez
le mascaret est au rendez vous
une vague de trois mètres qui barrent
toute la largeur de la rivière et qui
fracasse tout sur son passage
[Musique]
le jet ski permet de s'en approcher au
plus près ou de s'en échapper quand il
le faut
[Musique]
massa le surfeur japonais le premier à
se jeter
la vague ont fait qu'une bouchée
certes il ya le brésilien tente sa
chance à balai
le mascaret n'est pas une banque comme
les autres il est sauvage solitaire
rapiteau imprévisible la partie n'est
pas gagnée
on va pas ici au caire est de ce côté
anthony manade ans il faut slalomer
entre les bateaux se jouer des courants
des épaves et des hauts-fonds facile
être
le bateau vient justement de ces
chaleurs et la vague elle n'a pas prévu
de dévier sa trajectoire ok tout va bien
ça va
tout va bien
tout va bien le deuxième bateau stopper
lui aussi est embarqué avec le flou les
passagers abandonnent le navire les uns
après les autres
tout va bien
dans le courant anthony garder le sang
froid il tente de sauver ce qui peut
encore l'être ok je vais essayer de
redémarrer
fini de rire il y a huit personnes à
sauver est-ce que tout va bien ça va
et bleu elle l'a emballé
pour les surfeurs
c'est la douche froide
là on s'est plantés comme des cons
[__] quand des comptes
le pack
watteau n'y a eu de la chance la
deuxième bateau beaucoup moins l'urgence
maintenant c'est d'éviter qu'il ne
sombre et tout le monde y met du coeur
[Musique]
le bateau est sauvé le moteur est perdus
c'est comme ça anthony l' optimisme à
toute épreuve
magnifique et catastrophique à la fois
donc il ya vraiment une vague de co2 de
malades un mascaret de malades ici donc
là on est vraiment tombé sur un super
ok
bienvenu.merci
semblait sortir
expérience
c'était la première fois maintenant tu
sais à quoi ça ressemble c'est pas si
terrible
[Musique]
une pro tour en ville
la rumeur de la présence de surfer à
calcutta s'est répandue et pour finir de
cacher la journée au port c'est un drôle
de comité d'accueil qui attend les
aventuriers
à les paresseux en inde on ne rigole pas
avec les autorisations sauf que là pour
la police c'est un cas inédit des
surfeurs étrangers dans la rivière la
législation locale n'avait pas encore
prévu ça
quand vous voulez vous qu'on vous laisse
partir sans autorisation
super méchant
s'assurer de comprendre ce qu'on fait
un coup de fil bien placé
quelques billets sous la table un tampon
pour faire semblant et l'aventuré repart
troisième jour
[Musique]
on a perdu donc la matière on a vu qu'un
seul bateau donc certainement
pas pu en marquer mais comme souvent n'a
pas pu en marquer
je suis sacrifié
[Musique]
rien de tel qu'une journée de repos pour
se remettre les idées en place
direction le temple de thaksin et soir
au bord de la rivière ou bi anthony
vient ici pour mieux comprendre son
adversaire sort richir de témoignages et
c'est pas gagné
vous parlez anglais non vous parlez
anglais non désolé
même pas un petit peu non
quand la rivière est un paisible les
indiens y affluent c'est le quotidien
nous dit mais n'avait pas sa fin le
mascaret c'est celle
ci a été si pollué
le gange et ses affluents servent à tous
on s'y baigne on syllabes on y sème les
cendres des morts on y déversent les
eaux usées y les déchets industriels
c'est l'un des fleuves les plus pollués
au monde
cet ol est sale ou non
comment te dire oui la rivera était
polluée ça ne fait aucun doute a été
polluée donc elle ne l'est plus
si elle est toujours pollué
mais nous croyons au plus profond de
notre coeur qu'elle est totalement pur
pour nous elle est comme une merde et
notre mère ne peut pas être ça
pour les indiens le gange et ses
affluents sont sacrés leurs eaux sont
vénérés dans les temples ont les loups
on les honore on craint leur puissance
dévastatrice
si vous voulez prouver votre courage
face aux forces de l'eau et du feu alors
malheur à bout
[Musique]
s'il pensait que vous pouvez être assez
brave vous n'allez pas vivre très
longtemps sur cette terre
au matin du quatrième jour les nouvelles
ne sont pas bonnes
un bateau a chaviré bingo trois
personnes sont mortes
ça fait plusieurs bateau naufragé noyer
le poisson dans l'eau quand tu veux mon
riz paddy attentivement il se sent dans
un projet fort soit mieux ailleurs
quelque chose soit il sera histoire donc
on peut imaginer que ça arrive assez
souvent
un bateau en moins la peur en plus
l'expédition a pris une drôle de
tournure
tout le monde se couche pour essayer
d'avoir le maximum de vitesse
à 3 sur le jet ski il faut prendre plus
de risques et se dire que cette fois
tout ira bien
la bague redouble de puissance en
fonction des bancs de sable et des
courants qu'elle rencontre gare à celui
qui se trouve sur sa route le combat est
engagé
[Musique]
de l'eau de l'eau
mais la persévérance finit toujours par
payer la bête se laisse enfin
apprivoiser s'offrant même sous toutes
ses plus belles formes
[Musique]
oui
beau boulot
j'ai tellement mal aux jambes ça me
brûle
mais quand elle fait lever c'était
dingue j'étais dessus j'étais dessus
waro c'était jouissif
[Musique]
il existe que d'une centaine de mascaret
à travers le nombre mais aucun qui leur
ressemble à celui ci c'est sur la quête
d' anthony vient de prendre une nouvelle
dimension
blogue
l'histoire n'est pas terminée le surf
est né à calcutta est dans le coeur de
ses habitants et peut-être qu'un jour
ils iront à leur tour défier la bac 5
[Applaudissements]